in through the looking-glass palace has
become a boss she's following her dream
she's doing impossible things long too
long
pretty fearless and she is what we would
call a modern woman Alice we need you
the Hatter is in great danger he was
Karen was the first person to put on a
girl really as those here over but how
does in need I will help
he was very keen to kind of convey the
girls that he knew in their strengths
and I think Mia helps that character be
the character than those cowards under
me
Lewis Carroll wrote this incredibly
inquisitive curious smart girl
who was not intimidated by anything what
are you waiting for let's go else is a
great character she's very much her in
person how does the Sun's up for what
she believes in and it's being fragile
and very much her and self I think Linda
Woolverton has really done brilliantly
are using all the iconic characters I
was quite excited to come back and play
Alice sorry I got to work with the most
fun people I've ever worked with and all
of it and Wunderland what more could you
want
rated PG